thank you
[Music]
so when I was told by Ryan coogler that
wakanda forever was going to involve a
great amount of swimming I was extremely
excited I am I believe I'm a swimmer
um
you might have to ask others if they
agree uh but I've always loved the sport
I grew up with it and the one thing I've
never seen is a lot of bipart people of
color on screen in water navigating it
but as we started to train I started to
realize a lot of my castmates were
learning from scratch and it really got
me invested in what is it about us and
this sport which is more than a sport
it's a life skill it's the difference
between life and death in in many
circumstances and that led me to start
learning more and more about this
astounding icon sitting next to me uh
who I've admired for many years and
definitely started to pay attention to
once I saw her win the gold medal and
the 100 meter freestyle in 2016 at Rio
and from then on I was very interested
in her and and her voice and she has
really used it and that is none other
than Simone Manuel who is a astounding
athlete but also someone who has brought
astounding awareness to this issue I
wanted to sit down with you today
because this issue has become something
that um I'm very aware of only because
it is life and death like a statistic
that knocked me on my butt and really
made me want to start investing time and
energy into this is the fact that 5.5
times more likely a black child between
the ages of 5 and 19 is to drown then a
white child and that alone uh really
really floored me but to start it off
you are the sustounding
multi-olympic Medalist winner you are
also a multiple NCAA uh Champion 30
under 30 Forbes sports list and of
course the founder of the Simone Manuel
Foundation which we're going to get into
a lot as well it is so great to have you
here today Simone love our girls is all
about celebrating women and girls who
are leaders who are groundbreaking who
have organizations that are making
change in a world where women and girls
are still navigating our true equity and
freedoms so it is so exciting to have as
we call it at love our girls a girl we
love
on Deck awesome
[Music]
think
baby Simone would have experienced if
she had seen the sort of representation
that is there of people of color in the
water that wakanda Forever presents I
think baby Simone would have been so
excited to see wakanda forever and all
the beautiful black bodies in bodies of
water just swimming and being very
powerful would have inspired her to not
give up to to feel like she wasn't alone
in the space and that she could be
successful in the sport I'd love to
learn about the navigation of this field
to being at the very top of it
um as a black woman in this world in
this country please let us know talk to
me about that yeah so I am from Houston
Texas and so it's really hot in the
Summers and so my parents wanted my two
older brothers and I to be able to go to
the pools in the summer and cool off to
have fun in the Texas heat they in some
way knew the Staggering statistics of
black children
drowning and losing their life to
swimming and so they put us in swim
lessons so I was in swim lessons at the
age of four really just with the
opportunity to to save my life and I
just love the water so much that the
second day of swim lessons I swam across
the pool and that kind of started my
journey in the sport just continuing to
love the water and continue to improve
and get better and I definitely had my
challenges along the way being one of
few in the sport and not feeling like I
fit in and looking around and seeing
very few of us was really a lonely place
but my parents just continued to
encourage me to do what I loved and push
through those hard times and it has
allowed me to reach the highest levels
in the sport which has been amazing but
the goal that I have is to hopefully
make the journey a little easier for the
people that come behind me I hope that
I'm being a voice to others to be able
to find their passion and love for the
sport but to stay in it because I know
so many who decided to give up the sport
because it was a lonely place I did love
this one shot in wakanda forever for
instance when Angela bassett's character
Queen ramonda is saving Dominic's
character and bringing her up through
water her and just navigating the water
so skillfully to save another black
person's life that to me was just so
powerful just thinking about that like
that's you you're Queen you know what
I'm saying I grew up swimming I was I
grew up in Zimbabwe which randomly does
have a very strong team has a gold
medalist um who went to my high school
Kirsty Carey Hill but um you know it is
it is uh something that you just kind of
did as a kid and my parents started my
sister off when she was very young when
we were growing up in our early years in
Iowa and I jumped in the pool as a two
as a two-year-old and wanted to learn
two and they just let me keep going and
so I've always loved the water and you
know stopped swimming when I was about
12 uh competitively I stopped because I
got a perm
um which I no longer have you can
I had one and I had one for a long time
and I wanted to preserve it and that was
kind of what stopped me you know teenage
stuff but the interesting thing is as an
adult when I go and swim
um when I go on vacation I love to be in
the ocean I love to snorkel uh I find
that very cleansing very renewing to be
in water I try to swim sometimes as
exercise but what I've noticed lately
and just just now and even in August I
was in Jamaica with a very astoundingly
successful capable really sophisticated
black woman once we got to the water
that all changed and there are a couple
close calls
um where the second one was she thought
she she thought she was in trouble but
she really kind of wasn't but the level
of panic and that it induced was was
quite frightening
um it really was like okay let me try to
let me try to teach you because this is
a skill you need to have as we're saying
it's more than a sport and it was that
just led me into the the the question
around found what is it with us as
people of color around this issue and I
just wanted to share one swim story that
I think sums it all up my mother had a
traumatic childhood experience around
water where she almost drowned and as a
result she never took us to any swimming
pools lakes or other bodies of water by
the time I became an adult and wanted to
join my friends on trips to places near
the beach and other activities centered
around water I was ashamed that everyone
could swim and I couldn't even now I've
been to pool parties where either all
the black people are swimming or none of
the black people were swimming I often
stay far from the water's edge because I
don't want to get pushed in the pool
ingest and have everyone realize I can't
swim as well as me potentially drowning
I have a lot of Shame around not knowing
how to swim but now my mother's trauma
feels like it's been passed down to me
and I feel too old to learn how to swim
in a pool with a bunch of kids
so I'm just curious have you have you
been hearing themes like this yeah I
mean absolutely it's it's generational
especially in our community and so there
are many grown-ups I've met who have
told me that they don't know how to swim
but because of that they've put their
children into swim lessons and then also
there's many that are very similar to
your story that they're so afraid that
they pass that fear down to their
children right I do think it's important
to just remind people of the fact that
swimming is a life-saving skill so the
earlier you learn the better but it's
also never too late to learn how to swim
just to get into a couple of the stats
79 of children in low-income families
have little to no swim ability or access
and 64 of African-American children
little to no swimming you know it's so
rooted in systemic racism it's rooted in
in how neighborhoods were zoned where
pools were placed
um when where black you know black
neighborhoods low-income black
neighborhoods did not get pools but
low-income white neighborhoods did and
and literally
segregation of pools literally being
done in northern states starting in the
20s and the 30s and how that then
becomes something that goes continually
and how the the the issues of the
disconnection leads to the phobias leads
to all those issues so I'm just curious
I want to go into what you are doing
about this because you were doing the
life-saving work yeah so the Simone
Manuel Foundation is really his mission
is really to provide resources and
education to buy Park children and
families to prepare them for swim
Readiness and swim safety and so for me
it's about education awareness
empowerment and storytelling and so I
really want to have people understand
why we don't swim and some of the
challenges we face but also provide them
with access and I think that telling my
story hopefully a allows people to
understand why we don't swim and I think
that it's going to hopefully save some
lives so I just wanted to make mention a
quote that you had and just wanted to
hear more about your experience around
the struggle of being an
African-American woman in this in this
field as I kept going in the sport I
asked my mom why they weren't more
African-American swimmers so we did our
research learning about Olympic
medalists Maritza McLendon and Cullen
Jones and sabir Muhammad and Byron Davis
you talk to me a little bit about that
Journey that you had to go on in order
to claim your space in the sport yeah so
I think I was about 11 or 12 years old I
came home from practice I was just so
frustrated
um I think I had been struggling with it
for a while of just the experience of
being at practice and being the only one
in my group that was black or not
feeling like I fit in going to swim
meets and being the only one in the
region that I was swimming in or one of
few and I asked my mom why there weren't
many people that look like me in the
sport why there weren't many black
people in the sport and she didn't
really know or wasn't really able to
articulate it in the manner that I
probably needed it so she was like let's
do our research and we found the
experiences of black people in slavery
and how at one point we were excellent
fishermen like we would go die for pearl
goals and then we were captured by the
water and then slavery and a prominent
way for us to escape was through the
water but often slave owners would say
that there were monsters in the water or
drown us and instill fear in us so we
stopped learning how to swim or even
being in that space and then you go to
Jim Crow laws and segregation and how we
were kicked out of pools or beaten and
battered around pools or Dorothy
Dandridge dipping her toe in the pool
and the pool being completely drained
our traumatic experiences for our
community and along with the lack of
access with pools being in the white
neighborhoods and just through that
experience I just learned that one we
had fear instilled in us and two we
weren't allowed to have access to that
space and so that creates that
generational fear or that generational
lack of desire to want to be in the swim
space
and I think that learning about that
experience or becoming more aware of
what we had dealt with and what my
ancestors had dealt with gave me kind of
the strength and this power to continue
to go back to the pool and just a new
level of motivation that I have this
opportunity and this right to be able to
swim I think that it allowed me to
understand that my ancestors weren't
really given the opportunity to be able
to swim but I am allowed the opportunity
to be able to swim and I'm not going to
let my loneliness keep me from
progressing in the sport and so it
allowed me to have kind of this newfound
perspective of the fact that I get to do
this and hopefully I can you know help
other people along the way through my
experience because I think it is
difficult to kind of hear about that and
see that but it was really helpful for
me to understand that I have an
opportunity to be in this space so I'm
going to take a up space that's
incredible that ownership that history
understanding where we're from
understanding the barriers we must break
understanding the trauma that has
disconnected us from our greatness
reclaiming it and not allowing those the
trauma to continue its cycle yes and
then excelling to the extent that you
have I mean that's everything that that
really has been my journey I know that
it's bigger than me I know that there
were people before me that didn't have
that opportunity and the goal is to
honor them but also help the people
coming behind me I want the sport to be
more than just one percent black
swimmers and so the more awareness we
have and the more examples we see of
black people in the sport of swimming I
think that it's going to allow the sport
to grow and we're going to see more
representation we're going to see more
than just one black person on the podium
I hope that we can see more than that
and when you have a community surrounded
around this conversation
and awareness and education it's a
really powerful thing to help save lives
I'm I'm all in I got very excited about
the the fact that there was going to be
some representation in the film that and
then of course learning more about you
has been and just amazing I am very
invested now in we have taken on a
responsibility with the representation
we've brought
um with the film and and we have to see
it through in terms of making sure that
we do help bring more people to the
sport bring more children to the skill
address this statistic in a very active
way and thank you so much thank you for
being here you are such an icon to me
and um yeah I didn't grow up seeing a
black woman in your position though I
loved the sport so now I get to see you
coming up doing your thing killing it
already creating such a legacy and all
those young black boys and girls who get
to watch you I'm so excited for them
because more more simones are coming yes
and that goal really excites me yes
thank you thank you
[Music]